monsieur le président mesdames et
messieurs les ministres mes chers
collègues la question s'adressait à
monsieur le premier ministre à l'heure
où l'association des départements de
france tient son congrès et je regrette
très fortement que ce ne soit pas lui
qui me répondent les départements sont
les coller sont les collectivités de la
solidarité suffisamment proche pour être
en contact avec les populations les plus
déshéritées suffisamment importante pour
assurer une solidarité entre les
territoires
aujourd'hui les départements sont au
pied du mur l'état ne compense que très
partiellement le coût du rsa et de l'apa
l'état leur fait supporter l'accueil des
mineurs non accompagnés
alors que cette charge relève très
largement de la politique d'immigration
et l'état rêve de fondre les
départements dans les métropoles
le coût du rsa et de l'apa augmente
inexorablement sur ses deux seules
allocations le reste à charge pour les
départements n'est plus supportable
par ailleurs il y avait 25 mille mineurs
non accompagnés en 2017 il serait 40
milles en 2018 et la contribution de
l'état ne dépassera pas les 16% alors
comment s'étonner que les départements
soit exsangue sur le plan financier
comment s'étonner que 30 d'entre eux
soit dans l'impossibilité de faire face
à leurs obligations
devant l'explosion de leurs dépenses
l'état fera passer l'année prochaine sa
participation à l'accueil des mineurs de
13 à 16% et vous annoncer une rallonge
de 250 millions d'euros sur une dépense
de 9 milliards
s'agissant des aides individuelles de
solidarité mais nous sommes loin très
loin du compte
alors monsieur le premier ministre
madame la ministre ma question est
simple quel avenir voyez-vous pour les
départements ont-ils encore le droit
d'exister à vos yeux la parole bien
madame jacqueline nouveau ministre de la
cohésion des territoires et des
relations avec les collectivités
territoriales pour deux minutes
madame là mais la sénatrice commençons
par la fin si vous voulez bien
il est vrai que les départements ont été
parfois menacés dans leur propre
existence
mais bien sûr ce gouvernement a décidé
comme vous le savez de respecter les
institutions et il n'y aura pas de loi
qui puisse ménagers l'existence des
départements
ceci étant dit la crise migratoire et
bien sûr au coeur des préoccupations du
gouvernement comme l'a montré la réponse
du ministre de l'intérieur à une
question précédente et je connais bien
sûr et nous connaissons les charges sur
les départements dans leurs compétences
de prise en charge des mineurs
non-accompagnés mineurs étrangers non
accompagnés
c'est pourquoi le gouvernement travaille
depuis ce printemps avec l'association
des départements de france pour
améliorer la prise en charge et le
financement des actions concernant ces
mineurs plusieurs actions vont être
mises en place dont dès 2019
et ça n'est pas négligeable c'était une
demande forte des départements nous
allons créer un fichier national qui
permettra d'éviter de multiplier les
procédures successives des évaluations
dans des départements différents
l'état assume pleinement sa mission
régalienne
en créant ce fichier national les
préfets pourront également procédé à des
répartition entre départements là encore
c'est une mesure pragmatique de nature à
éviter des situations locales très
tendue mais l'engagement de l'état est
aussi financier se traduit dans les
crédits plf 2010 9 à hauteur de 141
millions d'euros pour l'accueil de ces
mineurs par les départements
je m'emploie à la tête du ministère des
territoires qui m'a été confiée à
renouer le dialogue avec les
départements
c'est pourquoi nous avons décidé d'aller
plus loin après en avoir discuté avec
dominique bussereau au cours des trois
dernières semaines
pour améliorer encore la prise en charge
des mineurs non-accompagnés une fois
qu'ils sont placés au sein d'une
structure de l'aide sociale à l'enfance
le gouvernement a donc entendu veut
complet
créer demain expliciterait pardon demain
à rennes devant les présidents de
conseils départementaux et j'espère que
nos propositions seront également
entendus
chers collègues il vous reste 10 minutes
10 secondes à beaubourg évolue très bien
dix minutes on a pourtant le sentiment
madame la ministre que toutes les
décisions prises tendent à être anglais
les départements pour mieux les tuer la
dernière en date et pas des moindres
c'est le rappel de plusieurs millions
d'euros d'un dut perçues au titre de la
taxe d'aménagement et indus dont la
faute incombe à l'état